congratulations you just kicked off a
week of R&R in a tropical paradise and
best of all the travel isn't costing you
a dime because you used your flight
rewards card feels good to get something
for nothing doesn't it but air travel
isn't cheap and credit card companies
aren't known for their charity or
stupidity so what's the catch you might
be surprised to learn that that free
flight you just booked might be the most
expensive one you've ever taken starting
with the diner's club card in 1950
Americans instantly fell in love with
plastic within just a generation or two
credit cards went from being a perk for
wealthy world travelers to a practical
necessity used by over 70% of US
households and what's not so right as
long as you pay your bills on time
it's basically an interest-free loan and
then there's the rewards programs
cashback in-store discounts and of
course airline miles we call that
generosity how on earth did credit card
companies manage to coast 163 billion
dollars in profit in 2016 alone turns
out credit card companies make their
money in a few different ways they
charge merchants a fee for processing
your payment which is often passed on to
the consumer in the form of higher
prices and they sell user data to
marketers so you might get hit with more
advertising it's hard to quantify
exactly how much of those factors affect
you but there are more direct costs to
being a credit card user
[Music]
most credit card companies have fees
attached especially if they're an
airline or other rewards card missing a
payment or overdrafting will also incur
late fees or cash advance fees one study
showed an annual cardholder fee range of
twenty five to five hundred and fifty
dollars for cards linked to a rewards
program with the average annual fee of a
hundred and forty seven dollars you
might still say you got a good deal on
the flight but if you pay one hundred
and forty seven dollars for a free thing
it's not free just saying and simply
paying that fee does and guarantee
you'll actually receive any benefit
bankrate.com study found that 31 percent
of airline miles never get redeemed at
all that's at least in part because
airlines make it increasingly difficult
to actually cash in on your benefits
it's such a pain in fact that services
have started popping up like booking
guru that will help you pay for a flight
with your saved up miles for a two
hundred dollar service charge when you
opened your first credit card back in
college you probably told yourself that
you'd be responsible and always pay off
your full balance every month I mean who
would plan on paying the u.s. average
interest rate of 17 percent that would
be crazy well easier said than done the
New York Times reports that 60% of
credit card holders don't pay off the
balance they accrue each month even the
most conscientious of credit users can
have a car breakdown a week before
payday or an unexpected trip to the vet
for poor mr. Fluffles and even if you
never pay interest on your cards are you
really getting the better of the credit
card company or other credit card users
the company can afford to let you beat
the system only because they know that
other less perfect customers will more
than make up the difference
so you might say that your cousin or
friend who struggles with credit card
debt is helping pay for your trip
even if you can avoid fees and interest
credit cards still might be hurting your
ability to save money or pay off debt
how by subconsciously affecting your
spending habits
a study by Carnegie Mellon found that
spending cash activated the areas of the
brain associated with pain swiping a
card not so much a landmark study by MIT
found that on average subjects using
credit cards were willing to pay almost
twice as much for sports tickets than
those using cash according to the
Carnegie Mellon researchers the nature
of credit cards ensures that your brain
is anesthetized against the pain of
payment and rewards like airline miles
are specifically intended to encourage
you to use your card more often the
thought of earning a few more of those
sweet sweet points might be what pushes
you over the edge to go ahead and buy an
extra pair of sunglasses or splurge on a
fancier hotel even if you don't wind up
spending twice as much imagine how much
you could save if you spent just five or
ten percent less a year by using cash
that could seriously add up when you
take these less obvious costs into
account you wonder whether it's a better
idea to just buy it seven hundred and
fifty dollar plane ticket outright which
is not to say that you shouldn't cash in
your rewards if you have them or that
anyone should or even could forgo credit
cards altogether credit cards aren't
objectively good or bad they're a
financial tool like any other that has
costs and benefits risks and rewards but
it's in these company's best interest to
emphasize the rewards and downplay the
risks and it's in your best interest to
take a step back and look at the whole
picture and that's our two cents if
you're a music fan which I'm guessing is
most of you you should definitely check
out soundfield the newest show from PBS
Digital Studios sound field breaks down
our favorite songs and artists from all
genres from Bach to Beyonce the show is
hosted by two amazing musicians nari Sol
and Ellie Buckner who even come up with
an original song in every episode
check out sound field at the link in the
dooblydoo
you
[Music]